all right welcome um so I want to talk
about the Beauty and the Beast um yeah
the p sline is that python is a beauty
the GPU is the Beast so we're going to
separate this talk out a little bit
about the hardware and then about like
how you program in in Python um I am at
now at Nvidia I have been there at um I
think now8 weeks so I am brand new and
know almost nothing about Nvidia but
I've been programming on gpus I think I
gave this talk in 20 uh well I think
Andre Andre clockner gave the GPU talk I
gave the distributor talk at P NYC 2012
so we've been around a long time using
python gpus um the things have changed
quite a bit but um so longtime user of a
python new new Nvidia emplo so ask me
nothing about video I don't
know so let's start with just the Beast
what is this GPU thing um the first and
foremost is this concept of simt not
simd so most computer like when you take
your computer architecture class you'll
learn about five stage pipelines and
you'll learn about streams of data and
you know the kind of annoy tecture is
like you have a maybe multiple streams
of data and you give instructions to
those streams of data um uh GPU flip
that you're actually multiply going to
the thread level and so when you're
programming on a Cuda device you're
actually programming the the threads and
then the data is being scheduled through
uh through all those threads and we can
talk about why that that helps you first
and foremost it's extreme
parallelism you will have thousands of
threads coming through on one GPU
whereas in um a standard CPU you might
have on the order of eight um data
streams 32 maybe um so generally you're
getting much much more parallelism on
the the
the
mod and the other thing that is kind of
a curse but also a blessing is that you
get this fine-tuned memory management so
if you ever try to actually tell your
computer where to which bits of memory
to load it's very difficult right so
that comes back to the the way the
pipelines work and scal architectures
are rearranging your instructions as
your code gets generated and so forth
and so computers got so smart they know
how to schedule your data better than
you do except that gets in your way a
lot of times you go for performance so
gpus kind of step back and you can
actually with your programming at C+ and
cc++ you you're telling it I want this
register to load this memory and you can
control the register file the the L2
cache the L1 cache and so forth um this
was really complex for python
programmers most of which have never
even run a a Linker or manag their
memory and things like that this got L I
don't know what happened um sorry right
but so this is where a lot of folks kind
of stumbled in the world in the python
world how do I manage my memory and so
when we get to the python section we'll
talk a little bit about how people do it
today um it's a little bit different
than we did 12 years
ago okay so this picture here I like to
start here because this is this is like
the physical layout of um what's
happening on your chip this is called a
stream
multiprocessor where a if you look at a
CPU um and and this is all published in
the Harper architecture manual so if you
go to the manual page the white papers
that Nvidia they they give you all these
details so you know how your machine
works um but if you go to a GPU or CPU
you just have a five safe pipeline the
registers are kind of they're there but
you don't really know exactly how
they're laid out how the streaming
multiprocessor works is it it tells you
it's like we have a processor we have
our registers we have the file for those
registers and this the thread that's
going to be running on this processor
will can Will have fast access to this
register file and then you'll have a set
of these things that are all going go to
each other's register file through an
instruction cache um in here we have
some schedulers that you don't have to
worry about although it's good to know
that they're there if you're getting
maximum performance it's like how these
threads will be scheduled so think of
this as a really I mean now it's fourth
generation tensor core when they first
came out out there were you know very
simple processors attached to register
files that you can actually um index and
use very quickly um and
then so gpus were built for graphics and
so a lot of the things were kind of
built on top of textures and shaders
Technologies and so that's where some of
these lower level Technologies kind of
inter
operate so the the full implementation
of this thing we have have GPU
processing groups uh texture processing
groups and then for each texture
processing group you'll have two uh two
streaming multiprocessors so 144 of
these threads all at once each one of
these 128 Cuda threads per SM so each
one of these register files you can have
128 Cuda threads um and then things that
have happened since 2012 when I started
using these things now you have high
band with memory have much bigger caches
and you can in the link you can actually
talk to each and you don't have to go
through a CPU to talk to each GPU so
when you see eight gpus on a node they
actually are going to talk to each other
through NV link as opposed to going to
uh main computer memory and so on so
there's a lot more configuration and
fancy
things uh this is what the current Grace
Hare looks like and it's full scale so
each one of these are the M groups a lot
of these are a texture group and then
this block here will be the GPU group so
that you can imagine when these things
are scheduled all these threads run at
once all these threads run together and
you can split these things up a little
bit through virtualization but you kind
of have a block level where different
things are running all the time so you
can program each thread you can program
where your memory is going for but it's
going to schedule it on the system for
you so that's your your level
there okay
getting Val back a bit from the hardware
so we have some the 8 billion 80 billion
transistors on the Harbor architecture
which is the current Mainline
architecture um unfortunately it's very
hard to get so you see a lot of people
talking about the amp or the a100 or the
BTA architecture so often you these are
pretty similar but the harw is the
newest one um we've added a few things
such as the Transformer engine uh and
and these multi-instance U GPU systems
so that now memory can be handled a
little bit more automatically and
transform onto the system as you've come
into and we've exposed these in the C++
world but they don't always get exposed
in the python world as quickly and so
this is one of the reasons I'm here is
to help get more python out of these
chips quicker um but now we're able to
see a 6X uh performance because for
Transformers because we're able to
stream the tensor through tensor cores
and so forth and then another thing
that's pretty cool is um still um it's
come out and it's still evolving is
confidential Computing so that people
can't uh see what's going like they
can't inspect memory and things like
that even if you're virtualized and so
forth so um kind of helping people get
on the cloud faster things like that and
and so and then we've evolved the MV
link and the dynamic uh programming
construction
sets Okay take a step back what who
would use all this parallelism why would
they use all this parallelism
um anyone who checks in viia stock price
you know that they they're doing quite
well just because these um applications
of graphics and Computing G analytics
deep learning and so on have really
started to become very valuable to uh
society and so these are kind of where
we play if you have a very branchy code
that's you know I don't look at
maybe uh you know trying to create a CRM
type thing or graph or UI maybe not the
thing to learn right but if you if you
want the fastest kind of computing or
the fastest deep learning learning how
to use the the hardware can uh boost you
up uh quite quickly and it might only be
10x on a single card um but then you
start adding link and a card switch it
and then the faster connects um and the
dgx things then you can get to scaling
much quicker so there's like an
exponential scale and the compounds on
itself and that's why deep Learning
Systems it's like the Computing systems
have really embraced
CA okay so that's all good that's the
beast that's the thing we're trying to
get to work um but we're python
programmers we want things to be
beautiful um and as you can imagine
trying to keep track of every single
thread maybe not so beautiful sometimes
you got a lot of details to keep keep
track of so how are we try to work
around this so 2006 Cuda came out um and
P Cuda which is a rapper around Cuda
came out in around 2008 produced by a
graduate student at NYU um and he did a
good job of like getting the memory and
mapping the memories of the Python world
to the kudle world and so forth um back
then I still just wrapped mine in C++
code but he came around variable s to P
Puda I think maybe the the Tano was
probably one of the bigger use cases and
Tano was an early learning framework um
that Bas had its own compiler built into
it so when when you program for for
NVIDIA GPU we actually use a system
called PTX which is the virtual machine
as opposed was it um going straight to
the registers and files and whatnot PTX
actually is a a virtualization that
allows us to change the ISA underneath
the C so the instruction set so it's
changed nine times as we have nine
capabilities over the last 20 years or
so um and by going straight to the PTX
versus maybe the C code you can actually
get to uh a a little bit more performant
car you don't have to have the seat
overhead and so forth but it's also
stable through every single one of our
cards so that all nine architectures
you're able to to touch through the the
PTX and so Tiana was one of the first
compilers that did that um then n came
out and so NBA is a compiler for python
on basically python arrays and so then
we were able to do just in time
compilation and you didn't need to Lear
Cuda handled memory management and so
forth from there um we saw a a a big
uptick in uh the usage of python of
these things both tensor flow pipes
which came out with either xlaa or other
Technologies underneath that where they
were actually jitting to to the card
itself so I could write Python and it
would be Jed to the C
itself um cpai was cpai is kind of now
the kind of the big standard I mean it's
Puda was developed by a gr student and
and supported very well uh chainer came
out which was another
maybe not very wellknown
um deep learning framework but chainer
actually had cpai which was the the
numpy array interface um all bundled up
into the uh for a GPU and so cpai
survived and so Cai made it kind of
everyone did these de blending
Frameworks and like well hey it' be
actually even better if I just work on
the arrays themselves um
okay so once we had couie we actually
Nvidia invested in making data analytics
and putting data frames and graphs and
far as Computing on the GPU and making
that fast so now data analytics
algorithms such as XG boost and U and
and other data science things that maybe
not deep learning um could be applied so
once we had arrays we could actually put
these set of libraries on top of it and
the next talk they going talk a little
bit about some of the the work that's
come to other graic libraries and
whatnot or other uh libraries like psyit
learn using uh tools that were more the
library side um just like cpai the the
linear algebra was ready Jack came out
which which took out the tensor flows
xlaa and WRA it in a way that worked
with numpy um and since then we've had
quite a number of projects uh pop up um
Cuda python is just a the very lowlevel
version of of of Cuda and warp is a
realtime engine on top of uh Cuda that
can generate um simulations um open AI
Triton which is different from the
Triton that was mentioned in the
keynote um is another linear algebra um
generator and I'll show off that in a
little bit and then we have C numeric
which is a multi- node version of
numeric or of pip nump that
interoperates between U multi- node
multi
um and supports most of the nump syntax
and the future Mojo kind of come out to
hey we're targeting this as yet another
compiler so in the slide deck the
history we have kind of I say three
major systems the dpu enabled libraries
that are like coming out right now and
probably a lot of folks kind of if you
only just use P towards your tensor flow
you realize that way I can just hit the
GPU button and accelerate it and that's
great um that's probably where most
people kind of hit these things U stay
tuned for the next talk because we'll
talk about how to usey Lear in that same
PR right um the second is automated
systems um so like NABA Jacks and so
forth they will do the compilation for
you um and produce the register uh
management like that those systems are
uh kind of evolving it's opened Triton
there another one I'll show how that
works I think this is where a lot of
people they most bang for their butt
because often if your analytic isn't
implemented in your library you need
some way to create the um the code
that's going to run the GPU and these
automated systems give you like a very
quick way of doing that um and then
there's kernel authoring like the actual
writing the something that's going to
generate the C Level code um which
sometimes you need to do because as you
can tell like any automated system is
bound to break somehow and so there's uh
tools for
that um so yeah so major if you're
looking for just libraries right uh
major things to check out is Rapids
which provides both a data frame Library
a graph system and a spars linear
algebra system for running on a GPU um
and with with those on and that sits on
top of a whole bunch of other libraries
and make can integrate with things like
Network X and um pan do and so forth so
that we can speed up your analytic code
so depending on where your fundamental
data structure lies you can kind of grab
the various data science libraries on to
of Rapids and then there's a ton of
other third party libraries say that win
P flow all have a GPU story at the point
so those are great and we'll learn a
little bit more about Psy Lear here
now um using automated systems there's
kind of two flavors there's hey I have
an array system so like cpai and jaxs I
have a numpy array you just give me my
array and I say I call numpy operation
on that array and then it kind of
figures out um how to call the me how to
push the memory over and how to call
that and so forth um and then the other
side of that is just in time compiling
which I mentioned and these systems
really are focused on taking your python
code and turning it into something that
can run on a GPU generally these days
it's it could go there's different
interfaces that could hit uh numers
hitting PTX open AI is actually
generating to a a system called cutless
which is a uh Nvidia supplied library
that exposes the newer tensor core
systems so like the original systems
were just register files and shaders now
um in that picture I heard had to point
it out but there's actually a a
scheduler that will schedule sensor
operations through tiles and things like
that and so um open AI Triton is using
that um oh and P torch compile so P
torch is being Rewritten in in Python
completely and it's using most of it's
underneath is python is open the ey
Triton for it actual compilation level
layers so just to give you a flavor like
using these elated systems so here's
like an example of number code um say I
have a uh just a simple function I'm
going to add um two vectors put on into
a third Vector here
um first and foremost you say I need I
need my thread ID because I need the ID
each one of those threads is going to
know how to get its ID so when it get
scheduled um the SDK is going to get
each one an ID and when you have your ID
oh sorry there's a
block there's a block ID and there's a
thread ID and remember how I said those
things were like all these run then all
these run then all these run so that's
done by blocks and threads
um and you get your
um sorry I need to proof you my code
better um your ivx is actually the comp
is the the usual thing where you comply
comp combine your blocks and your your
number of threads together so you have
threads box and then you get your actual
ID for the thread to work okay um and to
set that thing up you basically set up a
grid you set up the block size and then
you actually can pass this into the
function usually these things are you
know templatized or in this case we're
saying oh we have an interface that
tells our a kernel like run it in this
shape and this is how we'll um execute
on the system and we just give it our
lar our actual XY and Z vectors and
these are D vectors they can come from
various different places coui is
typically what you're going to use I'm
create manua like a n array I'm going
pass it now one thing to note is that
the these things here these are not
pointers in C and C++ world we like to
just pass the pointer and let the system
taking over things um now but because
it's trying to emulate the actual array
system you'll just pass it in kind of
normal arrays that you have allocated on
the CPU or the GPU
device um open AI straighten code
basically removes the need for the the
um thread level and you just come
through and you have an ID and you got
your index and instead of using um uh
the nump arrays they actually are doing
a trick where they actually bring in the
pointer and you actually load the
pointer and you do your math and with
some poter arithmetic um and you save it
up but the nice thing about this guy is
like I have to define a thread and then
I can let the the system schedule this
uh in
in maybe a better way so there's a a lot
more streaming things that can happen
under the uh Tri code base and so now
you're utilizing that streaming memory
you don't have to think about memory
very much at all whereas when you get
into like num but and optimizing CPUs
often using which thread is loading what
thing and you can get a lot of tuning
out of that whereas this one you didn't
have to worry about that you just say
here's a thread and it system because
it's using pointer
can kind of figure out the the structure
pattern underneath and actually use the
the streaming uh multi-or syst or the
streaming of multi tensor systems
underneath so those two really good ways
to get started if you've never done real
like lowle Kuda programming um and at
some point you're going to need to write
your own kernel um cpai has a great
system that just takes a string uh takes
your your Cuda string and turns it and
runs it over the number of one Cuda
python is
our where we came out with Cuda python
was often people wanted were wrapping
these systems and they were often behind
the sdks and so Cuda python is our
lowlevel rapper so generally mostly used
by these automated systems but if you
want to get the latest features from a
Cuda system Cuda python to check out and
pudas there is the B of the community
that's been around for a long time and
are our first MERS to be
used okay
that is the the Beauty and the Beast
just as a recap gpv ecosystem really
flipped parallelism on its head you can
you manage your memory you can manage
your your parallelism of your threads
and you can really tune your algor to be
very fast um the python ecosystem is
bringing a lot of automation to the uh
the world of GPU programming and through
several kind of neat things that you
look through the right interface which
will be talking about in The Next Top
um is coming to things that didn't have
it before like psyit learn and more
traditional
libraries I think that I'll open any
questions um I'm not I'm not very good
at GPU so this could just be an question
but you kind of really lost me on the
example I didn't understand how you why
you're accessing that thread ID I didn't
understand why had to
care just go
that sure
um so remember up here where I said
here's each s uh every core and every
register and unit you're going to be
programming on um so you have to tell
this thing which part of your Matrix to
load so when you load like a matrix
you're going to load um the whole Matrix
but I if I have a a thousand by thousand
Matrix even though I have um 128 cores I
still I still have to like schedule
those things through so I'm telling
every one of those 128 cores which part
of the Matrix to load I do that through
my my thread IDs okay so when I come and
and you can imagine you're using the
entire board every one of these things
is given an ID and so when I'm telling
and that's how I how access the memory
so I I load from my CPU into my L2 cach
my my majy will get loaded in there and
then when I say hey I want to add a and
z that's been loaded here actually tell
the thread index will be mapped to one
of these things it will load from the
memory to the registers and that's where
the and so the one of the differences
between open AI Triton and number number
you're absolutely referencing every
single one of these the block would be
the full block and so um one trick we
use um in the computer world is that I
the whole block every time and say I
only need you know this many slots so
there's effectively there'll be a mask
that comes in and says do I accept this
threat or not and so that those get
developed those are all done by the
schedule underneath the hood there's
this is the memory controllers I think
if you read the paper there's actual red
U execution layers orange part of the
top or whatnot but so so that being said
like if I want I can actually register
which piece of memory is going into the
block based upon those threat idas and
BLS thank
you
yes I'll claim gos will not be that up
on
gpus um of all the libraries assuming I
just want to play with it at home do any
of them have a good have a better than
the another
tutorial from standpoint of like here's
16 things that you can build up
to I think if you're brand new to like
and you want to do things on gpus my my
recommendation would go through the pie
torch tutorials right like P torch is
kind of already exposing um its tensors
and things like that in a nice way
especially this compile functionality so
um
now P gives you the ability to compile
your own kernels and run them on the
tensors and so forth um but if you're
more interested in doing actual data
like data science work Al then you might
switch over and look at Rapids and
Rapids has like a lot of tutorials on I
just doing pandas on this thing and I
have to run maybe some uh like XG boost
on pandas is a is a great example where
how need run classification and refresh
algorithms um they're more traditional
on these cards and so those are probably
where I would start um but then n by try
can come in later is to if I want to
write my own linear library or I want to
write my own s Computing system
analytics I would I would pick one of
those um and both have great tutorials
lots of YouTube talks and so forth so
check hi uh I know we're very focused on
like the future and where a lot of the
stuff is going and how great A lot of
these new Frameworks are but as a person
who when I was unemployed the one thing
I did to keep myself entertained was um
trans transpile um Google's deep dream
uh from Python 2.7 to Python 3 and part
of the challenge of that is just how
poorly a lot of this Ai and GPU stuff is
aged and you know we've moved on we go
straight from uh what was basically
nothing you know when people thought AI
wouldn't amount to anything and and uh
cnns were very primitive to now we have
this whole ecosystem for stable
diffusion and stuff like that so really
my question is I mean you know what I
had to do is build a container that had
uh all the depths like uh Ubuntu 18
bionic Beaver you know stuff like that
that that Cuda is locked to that version
of um Ubuntu and I was just wondering
like what does um backwards
compatibility look like for these GPU
architectures what does data
preservation look like for this if you
want to you know look back at these
older models and interest
for yeah um
so so to rephrase your question a little
bit like like how how does Cuda manage
the stability over time now all the
other stack you're right like there's a
lot of CH like how people distribute
things and how that all works gets
pretty complicated um so Cuda itself has
uh has had nine compute capabilities and
so if I so whenever you download a two
different program it's going to say this
is
this program requires and there's a list
I mean actually pull up the Wikipedia
page and like the feature you need
perhaps um and it'll say which uh Cuda
compatibility so you need to have a car
that actually can do whatever Isa is
coming out of it but the promise is is
that if you um if you program to Cuda
capability one it's going to work on all
the cards right um and that's the cards
from all the way back to uh 2006 that
are enabled and each car will say which
compute levels they enabl um that
doesn't mean that 2006 software will
work that means that the Cuda system uh
will work so if I compile to the uh PT
so that's where PTX comes in PTX is the
virtual machine that's going to generate
the commands to the card um so now how
do you how do I get Bionic Beaver to to
use my car that's that's maybe a wider
discussion about how we distribute
software in general in the python World
um but that's probably one of the things
that's differentiated Huda from all the
other kind of U
GPU standards is that it's it's been
around since 2006 and it's involved over
time and there's a strong uh stability
to keeping things the older things
running on cards still yeah it's like
age better than mantle in that respect I
I definitely agree with that yeah
hi thanks for the talk um I had a
question sort of looking at your long
history in the space and thinking about
like as a community um how users you
know the interface is very different
from these types of tools that you laid
out like Jax versus High torge versus
writing R Cuda and users now have all
these tools available to them in Python
when they're trying to Target this
Hardware do you have a sense of as a
community like um how what pces are
missing say kind of in this ecosystem to
uh kind
of like like kind of looking at the
history and where things have gone like
where do you see things going where are
the big holes today and where do you see
like uh new tools emerging or
integration between these tools like
obviously it's a messy place because
there's lots of different things
happening at once and that can be
confusing for users so I'm just curious
how you see that evolving in any way
yeah I think so one of the so the next
talk I think it's in this room I don't
see Thomas here yet um but
uh is so the standards are starting to
be put out in the python world that so
there's the array the data array uh
interface standards um and the array
interface is kind of changing it so now
uh because there's a lot of different
arrays out there right like we grew up
on numpy and numpy was the answer uh but
now you have quite a few things that are
implementing these such as like a coupy
array or um C numeric which is a
distributed array right and so the
community is starting to say all right
look there's more Rays out there here's
an interface that if they all actually
Implement our code will work on top of
it and for folks who maybe haven't
didn't know the history like C so when
Travis olant started scipi he was he was
trying to bundle up a lot of Fortran
tools and then he quickly ran out the
problem that you have to share your
arrays between things and so he grabbed
uh num expert and uh no numeric and uh
namare I think or something and and put
them together there's two interfaces
that were being kind of built
independently and so then he built CPI
on top of it and so the idea was oh I
can just replace my array system and I
get all a CPI right didn't quite work
that way but it's it's kind of a nice
model and and napai has become the
standard now numpy itself um is still
like a single node single threes
system and and you can get an multi
Bloss kind of onto it and then you can
also especially pandas like we just
talking about py Arrow well P aro's got
its own threat executor now and so now
you have like and then if I have couie
underneath I have three thread execution
systems all going at once um and these
will cause some problems on your system
um with over subscription and things
like that so working with the community
to come kind of have like hey we we
actually need to think about threads
again
especially the no Gill stuff kind of
percolating um I think that's the
biggest kind of challenge that the
python Community has is like how do we
actually embrace all the levels of
parallelism that are being presented um
and interface systems such as the the
data array interfaces we have a Cuda
Cuda array interface maintained by
number that we're trying to bring out
and things like that um so better
interfaces for understanding the
execution of your python is probably
going to beig big Topic in the next you
know year as no Gill comes out and
pandas takes on the array inter or the
Arrow interace by default and now you
have so today if you spit up pandas
you're going to get a a threaded system
because open BLS will spin up its
opening P threads and so now if I have
an opening P thread and a an arrow
thread pool you're going to have to
manage all that so we're we're I think
that's the biggest challenge the
community has right now is like just man
coming
out I don't is
there a difference in performance
between a jit uh function and if I wrote
my own C Kel um certainly there like the
jit has to jit right um so if you write
your own and you expose through like a
library um what will happen is the nvcc
will actually generate the PTX right and
PTX itself has whenever cud is actually
um distributed it'll have all the
different generations of architecture
isas set up so you can uh link straight
to that Isa implementation which one of
the reasons it's so big like it's one of
the largest packes of of pii because
it's got tons of uh things to support
all the different generations of cards
so when you do nbcc it's just going to
generate that and Link directly to that
so the startup cost is going to be there
um but at the same time if you do that
you now have to manage your own memory
and so um where like so it's hard to
give you like a benchmark because you
look at open a Triton it's actually
going to utilize the the tensor core
streaming system through and so like the
memory uh the memory challenges become
uh alleviated and they get to use the
hardware version of that and so yeah
maybe you can just compile to cut lless
which is the underline tool and and save
that jitting overhead but at the grand
scheme of things like we want the
productivity not necessarily the like
everything else is speed so um start
with open AI Triton and then move to
compiling Cuts yourself or something
thank you
everyone